واوكرانيا التي تحتل المرتبه 116 من بين
180 دوله في مؤشر الفساد العالمي لمنظمه
شفافيه دوليه تواجه ضغوطا متزايده لمواجهه
الفساد المستشري في عدد من مؤسساتها تعمل
على اصلاح نظامها القضائي والتصدي للرشوه
والكسب غير المشروع تسعى الحكومه
الاوكرانيه الى بدء محادثات بحلول نهايه
العام بشان الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
غير انها تحتاج اولا الى تلبيه العديد من
المتطلبات الاوروبيه يتعلق معظمها بمعالجه
الفساد
في هذا الوقت تم اعتقال رئيس المحكمه
العليا ويجري اتخاذ تدابير للتحقق من
الاشخاص الاخرين وتورطهم في الجريمه
الجنائيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات